hi there Steve coffin here I just wanted
to do a video because it's really yeah
we're a week away from the meetup in
Prague the second of October in the
evening at the noble missed ski novum
uski people are and I'm going to put the
link to that pub here just underneath
the video yarda has told me that he is
going to reserve a table in the
non-smoking area of this pub we're going
to sample some good czech beer hopefully
speak Czech the whole time I'll go I
gather there's some people there who
don't speak Czech but most of the people
there will be speaking Czech I think
will be a group of vote 10 people or so
so I'm looking forward to seeing you and
if favre you can make it please do so
please let me know you know and it makes
me it sort of reminds me that while
there are some people who have to learn
languages for their job or because they
emigrated somewhere but for most people
i was learning has to be about fun and
so I mean I'm really looking forward to
going to Prague to speak Czech I've got
to figure out what I can do in order to
be able to speak all day long and I was
thinking maybe I could even find out if
there's like a you know a senior's club
cuz he has got time on their hands
they're happy to talk I could go there
and talk about you know language
learning in the internet or life in
Canada or whatever they're interested in
find out about the Czech Republic and
speak Czech might you know that might be
one opportunity I'm certainly going to
go and find pubs outside the center of
the city where there aren't so many
foreigners get on the bus probably
transportation system and try and sit
beside some people that might want to
talk to me in check well anyway my goal
there is to try to speak as much check
as I can now that I've had a good year
or so of predominantly past
Ernie but yeah it's got to be fun and
that's where you know just saw the other
day that Benny the Irish polyglot is off
to Brazil to learn Arabic to prepare for
eventually going to Egypt now I don't
know how he does it but I gotta hand it
to him that if I were his age and I
could charge around to different
countries and learn different languages
I mean I think that's a great thing you
do what a tremendous tremendous
experience he'll never he'll never
regret that I mean his even has his
brief exposure to Chinese his exposure
to these different languages and now he
loves being in Brazil is going there and
he's gonna study hard to learn Arabic
and then he's going to go to Egypt and
meet people up there me he's perhaps an
extreme example of someone who makes up
basically a full-time occupation out of
the enjoyable pursuit of language
learning but ultimately yeah it has to
be fun it has to be fun and it sure is
fun for me last few days I've been
watching check movies some comedies some
you know modern movies I saw a couple of
movies from the night from 1937 one
called the villain emotes which is a
book a movie by Carol topic which was
made in 1937 and so two years before
Hitler invaded Czechoslovakia and it was
pretty you know prescient really in the
way he anticipated and maybe it was
clear for at least some people to see
the what what was coming with with
Hitler in Germany and plus the idea that
you're put back into the 1930s and in
Czechoslovakia those are people from
that time that are speaking and it's
just it's just a tremendous tremendously
enjoyable thing to do so that's it
please if you're in Prague or near
Prague come and join the meetup I look
forward to meeting you there and thank
you for listening and you know what i
will do some i will do some videos from
prague promise
and then be going to Portugal and Spain
so i'll probably do some in Portuguese
and Spanish from Portugal and Spain if i
can get my my mind unwound from my check
experience okay then thanks for
listening bye